>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Gulsun Saglamer,
thank you for being with us.
It's a privilege for us to have you.
And you are the president of the
Technical University of Istanbul.
And as I heard yesterday, not only
the only one who is president,
the only woman president of
such an institute in Turkey,
but the only one in Europe.
And probably one of the
very, very few in the world
who has reached this position.
Why don't you tell us
something about your background.
Where did you grow up?
How did you make it [laughs]?
>> Gulsun Saglamer: Well, thank
you very much for inviting me here.
It's a great honor for me.
And in terms of technical
universities
and technology universities,
the information is right.
I'm the only female director
in the Europe among the
technical universities.
And we are going to hold a
meeting at the end of this month,
a directors meeting called
technical universities
and technology universities in
Istanbul Technical University.
So we are very active as a
network at European level as well.
So if you look at my background.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb:
Your background, yes.
>> Gulsun Saglamer: My background.
I was born in the Trabzon which
is small city along the Black Sea
Coast, Eastern part
of Black Sea Coast.
And it's a historical city.
And I was born there in 1945
just after the Second World War.
And I brought up there and
until 17, I was in Trabzon.
And when I was nine years old, I
fell in love with architecture,
and I decided to be an architect.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb:
What inspired you?
>> Gulsun Saglamer: Well, I think
all the buildings around us,
you know, historical buildings.
And new ones also came in
at that time, you know,
several buildings started to
be constructed in Trabzon.
So all of these activities
created important impact
on my decision, I believe.
And I also read a book about
architecture in the schools.
So it was a very impressive book,
and I couldn't find
it later on, you know.
So afterwards I checked where could
I study architecture in Turkey,
and I realized that ITU
is the best place to go.
So when I was ten years old,
I decided that I should go
to Istanbul Technical
University to study architecture.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb:
So you started young.
>> Gulsun Saglamer: Yes.
So I started like that, and I came
to Istanbul when I was 17 years old.
And I graduated from
Istanbul Technical University
for architecture.
And I started as a research
assistant in the university.
And I got all of my
degrees from my university.
My PhD is also my from university.
And I worked with many
research groups at the national
and international levels.
And I have been very active in the
international networks as well.
So all of these activities
and research activities
as well brought me to
the vice directorship
in the university in 1992.
So I served as a vice
director for four years,
then afterwards the director decided
not to run for the next period.
And then I decided to
run for directorship.
And at that time people
told me that, well,
it's not easy to be elected because
they said that I am a female,
I'm a woman, and I'm an architect
in a technical university.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb:
Architecture is not quite.
>> Gulsun Saglamer: Not, yes.
It's not, you know,
very well represented,
I believe, in the university.
So I have never thought
of, you know, such a case.
Because, you know, if you
would like to do something,
I've never have an idea that.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb:
That you cannot do it.
>> Gulsun Saglamer:
That I cannot do that.
So I told them that
this is nonsense.
I mean, it has no.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: No relation.
>> Gulsun Saglamer:
No relation at all.
So we started to work with our
colleagues to prepare the project
and program for the four years.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: An
architecture program?
>> Gulsun Saglamer:
Not architecture.
The whole university.
We created the very extensive
project, many projects, in fact.
But there was an umbrella program.
So when we started campaign, I
started to tell about our projects
and program to my people and
in our system [inaudible].
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: For director.
>> Gulsun Saglamer: For director.
So I talked to the people face
to face at least half of the.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Faculty.
>> Gulsun Saglamer: Faculty, yes.
But on the other hand,
I also organized many small
meetings in the departments.
So and then I had the most votes,
and I had nine male competitors.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Oh, really?
>> Gulsun Saglamer: Yes.
But I got the most votes and
six of the candidates were sent
to the higher education council
and higher education council
elected three of them according
to their achievements
and their program.
And as I was on the first place
in the list, they didn't touch it,
and they also brought our program.
And higher education council sent it
to the president of the university,
and the president of the
university appointed me.
That's how it started.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb:
>> Gulsun Saglamer: Yes.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: What about
your family, your parents?
Were they supportive
of your choices?
Did they like the idea that
you were going to architecture?
Or did they think architecture
is for boys?
Or did they think, no?
>> Gulsun Saglamer: No.
I think, as I said yesterday,
I have never had any.
I have never observed
any obstacle around me.
Always my family and my
environment was very supportive.
And because they wanted
girls to study,
to go further to have good
positions in the society.
So my family, my father
was a businessman.
And although there wasn't lots
of women around at the top level,
you know, in the small and Italian
city, but they supported me.
I have two brothers older than
me, they supported me as well.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb:
They're architects?
>> Gulsun Saglamer: No.
One is engineer, mechanical
engineer.
The other one is economist, so.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: I see.
So each one of did his own thing.
>> Gulsun Saglamer: Yes.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Yes.
>> Gulsun Saglamer: And
but they all supported me.
And when I came to Istanbul, you
know, it was my dream came true.
I mean, I'm Istanbul
Technical, I'm in the university,
Istanbul Technical University.
And I'm studying architecture.
It was the most beautiful dream
that I realized in my life.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: And did
you work in architecture?
Did you build?
>> Gulsun Saglamer: Yes, I did.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Tell me.
Tell me about it.
>> Gulsun Saglamer:
Well, I love designing.
I have designed lots of buildings,
hotel buildings, housing units,
settlements, and bank
buildings, office buildings.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Here in
Istanbul or all over Turkey?
>> Gulsun Saglamer: Many places.
The last one that I designed
when I was the vice director
of the university is the nursery
buildings of the university.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Oh, really?
>> Gulsun Saglamer: Yes.
And.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb:
How did you design it?
>> Gulsun Saglamer: Well, I,
it's a very interesting design.
Because I didn't want
to design something
which will remind us,
you know, homes.
Just the normal.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: The
traditional way of doing it.
>> Gulsun Saglamer: Yes.
I try to construct design a kind
of nursery that the students,
the children inside
the building will feel
that life is complicated,
not very simple.
So the space that I wanted
to provide is giving a kind
of impression that you
have different views
from different angles.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: How interesting.
>> Gulsun Saglamer: In
the main hall, you know.
So when you move inside the atrium,
you have completed different.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Perspectives.
>> Gulsun Saglamer: Perspectives.
So this recalled it as the
constructivist architecture.
So it's in that style.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: It's
a philosophical issue.
I mean, it is giving
children the idea
that there are different
perspectives to life.
>> Gulsun Saglamer:
Yes, that's right.
That's right.
That's what I wanted
really to obtain.
And this building got two prizes.
One is national, the other
one is international.
OECT, OECD in the year 2000 has
chosen about 50 buildings all
over the world, educational
buildings, to be awarded.
And my building is one of them.
So but I haven't designed anything
since then because I'm so busy
with directorship and
at the university.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: What are some of
the programs that you introduced?
You know, the programs
that captured the support
of the faculty and
who voted for you?
Because you said you created
a big umbrella with a lot
of different projects
for the university.
What are some of the projects?
>> Gulsun Saglamer: Well, you know,
just my university is a
traditional university.
It was established in 1773.
So this year we are going to
celebrate our 230th anniversary.
So it's a traditional university,
but we have had very young
academic staff in the university.
This young generation, you
know, always we started to talk
about restructuring our
university after 1980s.
We kept talking and working on
several aspect of the university.
We brought the solutions
to the administration,
to director, to the deans.
But we didn't get good, you know,
response from the administration.
So I think the motivation came from
the young academics that wanted
to change the university and create
a kind of flexible environment
in which we will be able, we will
be able to have constant progress,
constant innovation,
constant development.
And, you know, these
are the basic motives
that the people really wanted
to achieve in the university.
So our program showed
that it's possible.
If you want to change
the university,
it's possible to change it
and to restructure everything
and to have a flexible
environment in which we will be able
to govern the university in
a kind of organized anarchy.
Not very well defined, you know.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Yes, yes,
yes, to allow creativity.
>> Gulsun Saglamer: Yes, yes.
To allow people to create
many different, you know.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Innovate, yes.
>> Gulsun Saglamer: Yes, innovate
and create many different ideas
and to be able to realize them.
That was the main motives.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: So your faculty
is also creative and involved inside
and outside the university?
>> Gulsun Saglamer: Yes.
People say that, you know, when I
go to the international meetings,
people keep talking about
how difficult it is, I mean,
to change the traditional
university.
But the motives came from
our young academic staff
and also from our alumni.
This is very interesting
because alumni is very
powerful in this country.
We have two presidents, three
prime ministers, many ministers,
many important businessmen, and many
important scientists and engineers
in the country and
all over the world.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb:
So they're very proud
of their institutions
and they support it.
>> Gulsun Saglamer: Yes.
And they said that we have to
restructure our university,
we have to be dynamic enough to
adjust ourselves to the changes.
So alumni and young academic
staff created this atmosphere,
and I was just there.
>> Mary-Jane Deb: The catalyst.
>> Gulsun Saglamer: Yes, just, yes.
Just right time I was there.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: And you
brought them together and you were.
>> Gulsun Saglamer: Yes.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Well,
I have to thank you.
This has been a wonderful
experience for me to learn
about the dynamic director
that you are
and the way you have
inspired your faculty.
Men and women.
And I wish you the very best in
the future of your university
and in your own future
and that of your students.
And thank you so much
for being with us.
>> Gulsun Saglamer:
Thank you very much.
It has been wonderful
session for me.
Thanks a lot.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Well, it's
been our pleasure and our honor.
Thank you.
>> Gulsun Saglamer: Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.